there's an interesting article by
Jonathan ashbaugh in the Federalist
which argues that the best move for
Republicans is to elect Donald Trump and
then immediately impeach him making vice
presidential candidate Mike Pence
president of the United States and the
argument from Jonathan ash Bach is
arguing that conservatives don't really
have a good option in terms of elected
Trump and him being the president or not
elected Trump and Hillary Clinton being
the president jonathan ash box says both
options are bad so the move would be
let's not abstain from voting let's
ensure that Donald Trump wins and then
immediately impeach him making Mike
Pence president of the United States who
but this particular writer in the
Federalist says is a good guy and
morally a good guy although you and I
know that uh Mike Pence is just as or
more dangerous and insane and extreme
than Donald Trump so it's an interesting
idea I mean that the real impediment
here is that you need the President to
be guilty of high crimes and
misdemeanors to be impeached and it's
not a literal statement that needs to be
applied it's a phrase that's understood
pretty broadly in terms of its
application ultimately Congress can sort
of decide well is have there been high
crimes and misdemeanors here it seems
though like a very risky bet I if I were
a Republican I wouldn't be counting on
Mike Pence being the president by
impeachment of Trump yet it's not gonna
happen also because the Democrats look
to be taking the Senate most likely and
they're not gonna want to convict Trump
knowing that pence a more dangerous guys
gonna take over there was one email I
received about this article where people
said David you don't buy this right this
article is not really about elected
trumpet impeaching him and then actually
elected Mike Pence this is just about
electic Trump and this is an article
that's playing to those Republicans that
don't want Hillary elected but also
don't really like Donald Trump I don't
know i mean the Federalists doesn't
really have a reputation for for
propaganda in this way I mean certainly
anti progressive anti liberal propaganda
but I don't know that that's exact
what they're doing here and there
there's a really fundamental question
here for Republican voters who are not
in the trumpeter camp right the
trumpeters who don't care about 17
alleged Affairs who wouldn't care Trump
shot people on Fifth Avenue all that
stuff that we know about their voting
Trump period I'm super interested in the
Republicans that are more in the vein of
Mitt Romney although we see that Mormons
like mitt romney in utah by and large
running away from Donald Trump in many
ways or more than we've seen them do
previously John McCain Colin Powell
etcetera what do they see as the 2020
strategy because for them Pat if Hillary
wins they want someone else in 2020 if
Trump wins they probably also want
someone else in 2020 yet seems like the
Republicans would have a better chance
in 2020 if Hillary does win because
you'd have to unseat the incumbent
president that's unlikely yeah it's very
tough to primary unless unless you're
having a president that deliberately
only going to be there for one term and
you know honestly if anybody's gonna do
that it would be Trump who after he gets
in realizes that this is a disaster he
wants nothing to do with this if
anybody's going to bail after one term
it actually would be Donald Trump it's
very tough to unseat a UH a president in
the primary if they're not deliberately
backing out so I think this is very
unlikely and it's just yet another
indication of the totally desperate
state of the Republican Party right now
I've talked about how people of all ages
but particularly Millennials are owning
cars less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zip car which gets
you a car when you want it when you need
it they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zipcar
dot-com / David